que vous croyez ou non au père noël et
si vous cherchez des idées originales de
cadeaux avant de prendre votre billet
pour new york
je vous propose de découvrir en
compagnie de briller de l'air les
nouveautés en matière de jouets aux
etats unis new york peut-être la ville
la plus branchée du monde mais s'il ya
un événement sur lequel on ne transige
pas ici c'est bien la tradition de noël
la ville est fière d'avoir le plus aux
sapins du pays
les boules décorées les plus
gigantesques et des étoiles des neiges
particulièrement élégant l'esprit est le
même pour les jouer
quoique demande des enfants qu'on leur
fait toujours faire un tour phare et
c'est au choix mais l'ange d'alice au
pays des merveilles et du magicien d'oz
la vénérable maison offre au regard des
familles en balade les plus beaux
automates de la ville et sa fine
évitables le département barbie la
blonde parfaite est toujours de rigueur
et s'enrichit au fil des ans de nombreux
amis la plus récente plus à la mode
aussi la barbie indienne qui
classification étonnante rejoint sur les
rayons ses copines chinoise et
hollandaise mais quand il rencontre le
père noël les enfants ne font pas de
chichis et dévoile sans gêne leurs
espoirs
moi je veux des powers est le maître mot
est lâché par orange le jouet qui depuis
deux ans séduit les peupliers rend fous
les grands
tout a commencé par une série télévisée
débiles qui raconte les aventures de
cinq amis gentillet consciencieux doté
du pouvoir de se transformer en
guerriers interstellaire dès qu'une
créature eni montre son museau les power
rangers sont revêtus de leurs plus
belles tenues moulantes de synthétique
la dissolvait d'un jet de pistolet laser
l'histoire est simple est mais le
business florissant chiffre d'affaires 1
milliard de dollars par an et ses usines
qui à travers le monde ne parviennent
pas à couvrir la demande
j'aime tout ce qu'ils feront surtout
leur manière de se battre
ils sont bien parce qu'ils tuent les
méchants leurs coups de pied leur coûte
quoi sont vachement cool pour les
enfants romantique surtout pour les
parents qui ont réussi à cacher la
télécommande de la télévision reste une
valeur sûre le dessin animé chez warner
superman fait faire un tour en un sens
ce batman vous fred son badge est et non
l ifa sylvestre continue de poursuivre
un titre plus intelligent que lui